this video is sponsored by exter welcome
to the 1990s the former Eastern Bloc a
beautiful wealthy inspiring place left
behind by the dying retreating Russian
Empire suppose he wanted to do some
shopping where will you go oh I know
those beautiful sovereigner shopping
centers seen by many on those Soviet
retro themed social media Pages full of
the finest Wares of the Eastern Bloc I'm
sorry I couldn't keep a straight face
there no if you wanted to do shopping
you did not in fact go to the shopping
center instead you went where the rest
of society went to dismal outdoor
markets selling vegetables knockoff
clothing homemade food preserves and so
on from Cars Vans often entire buses it
was chaotic dirty loud often taking
place on random sidewalks or in
underpasses as you milled around the
makeshift stands in the crowd looking at
the knickknacks being sold people
haggling old women counting coins in
their hands you thought of a photo you
saw of an American shopping center you
called it a shopping center because you
did not have a word for it yet that is
the mall beautiful clean air-conditioned
full of western stores underwears fast
food restaurants like McDonald's and
others you've never even heard about
people strolling around wearing the
latest fashion surely all of them are
drinking Coca-Cola and Pepsi Cola too
not this peace water they sell around
here palm trees fountains colorful
lights you're pretty sure there is
American rock music playing in the
background too you don't know it was a
photograph your thoughts are interrupted
as you look down and realize you stepped
into and an old lady is yelling at
you to move from her stand if you ain't
buying anything the shopping mall was
the ultimate symbol of 1990s Western
prosperity and it wasn't long before
they spread through Europe too including
the former Eastern Bloc today malls in
places like Budapest Prague or Warsaw
are basically indistinguishable from
their modern American counterparts
except for one thing malls in Europe are
thriving while in the US they are slowly
dying out why is that people often say
it's because of Amazon and online
Commerce but Europe has those too is it
a purchasing power issue but how America
is the richest country on the planet
lots of full wallets over there though
sometimes those wallets need replacement
and additional company this is where
Exeter comes in with their compact
stylish need part products some of which
they've sent me to try for myself the
extra wallet is nice and compact it even
has a button to get your cards out and
is strap to hold your paper cash it's
really Nifty and fits into every pocket
the keychain I was skeptical about but
it turns out it's a nice fit it has an
additional Loop to fit all the keys that
aren't flat you can even fit the
keychain finder into it which means if
you don't know where you put your keys
you can make this think peep within 60
meters using your phone it even has an
LED light if you have trouble finding
the keyhole at night the wallet tracker
is a credit card sized while tracker
that alerts you if you leave your wallet
behind it works via long range Bluetooth
up to 60 meters where you'll be able to
see your wallet's last location on your
phone and you can also ring your wallet
which is also pretty cool with 3 hours
of solar charge the tracker will last
two to three months so don't worry about
it running out the laptop cases icing on
a cake it's really nice classy and high
quality use my link in the description
to get up to 35 of extra products till
the 28th of June during exter's Father's
Day Sale big thanks to extra for
sponsoring today's video thus helping me
make more content for you and now back
to the program
so the most common arguments cited for
the death of U.S malls is online
Commerce the fact that people are now
able to order from the internet from the
comfort of their homes and sure online
Commerce didn't exactly help moles but
as I mentioned online covers is also
very much present in Europe and models
over there are doing fine so I'm
comfortable stating that the decline of
U.S malls is not because of online
Commerce though it certainly didn't help
and so I've identified three actual key
reasons which we will go through now
including the last one which no one
talks about but is absolutely crucial in
my opinion in fact that might be the
most important reason for the death of
U.S malls and yet people seem to ignore
it so let's go through the reasons
please
malls are only alive as long as they
have customers who can afford to buy
their stuff and in the US this isn't the
case everywhere entire regions lost
their well-paying jobs as industry went
offshore looking at the central us today
those Libertarians weren't joking the
free market really took care of those
regions as high-paying jobs left so did
many people those who stuck around were
considerably poorer and often couldn't
keep many of the malls alive so did this
happen in Europe well not really
European economies are built differently
especially those in the EU yes there is
a competitive capitalist Market but with
important quirks to illustrate this let
me talk about trains for a moment a
couple of weeks ago I went hiking
through the Czech Republic first I took
a train from Leipzig to chemnitz where I
met my friend the next day we took
another train to Dresden both of these
trains were operated by a company called
transdev then we went on to liberets on
a train operated by the company the
landerban finally from liberet we took a
train operated by ariva to jeles neprod
so private rail operators all the way or
were they ariva is owned by deutscheban
the German State Railway the landerban
is etern Italia subsidiary which is the
Italian State Railway and trans is
majority owned by the French government
and these state-owned companies compete
in free market tenders across the EU
where they try to offer the best price
they can to local governments to provide
real service on a given line usually
anyway it's an interesting mixture of
the private and the publicly owned it's
like a state capitalist free market and
it seems to be working pretty well all
this is to illustrate European economies
work differently and aren't subject to
the same types of shocks the U.S economy
is with very few exceptions European
purchasing power has been rising across
the board even in Central and Eastern
Europe the polar Parts indicated by this
chart and this increase has been more
geographically even compared to the US
so there aren't any continent-sized
newly appeared economic black holes like
the Rust Belt or such enormous
unaffordable urban areas like on the
west coast also in Eastern Europe major
regional economic depressions happened
before Moss came about so local most
Dodge dead bullet but they did something
else in Europe or rather they didn't do
something which Americans did
[Music]
American malls are exotic in the sense
that there are so many of them copious
amounts of commercial space was built
out in the form of enclosed malls
outdoor malls power centers lifestyle
centers and so on consequently there is
a lot more commercial space per capita
than in Europe a lot more like 10 times
more than Germany for example and in
German cities where there is an
oversupply like candidates the city I've
recently talked about you get the same
all deaths but Cambridge is an exception
because those malls and shopping centers
used to have a demand base it's just
that following the fall of the Berlin
Wall people started leaving for former
West Germany and suddenly there was a
commercial oversupply but such a
situation couldn't happen otherwise in
Europe as regulations that govern
building new commercial space are far
more stringent than in the US
Libertarians call this government red
tape crippling the economy while adults
call it necessary regulations to avoid
Mass closures and Urban Decay the large
number of U.S malls also means they are
of lower quality and more mass-produced
take a look at this one the former Metro
Center Mall in Phoenix Arizona why is it
falling apart like that what material
did they use cardboard if any
contributes that many modes it is
inevitable that many of them will end up
cheap and misproduced both inside and
outside both architecturally and in
terms of what they offer and the
mass-produced standardized consumerist
just isn't something people
look for nowadays compared to the Metro
Center mall to say Palladium in the
center of Prague this is the facade of
the mall that's a real historical
building into which they integrated the
whole thing and it continues on behind
it's a well-made building and the
interior is also high quality it's
actually right across an old Soviet Air
Shopping Center too so that's a neat
callback to the start of the video but
Palladium is a positive example in
something else as well the third reason
why U.S malts are dying namely
this is the issue I barely hear anyone
talk about when it comes to dying molds
yes purchasing power and oversupply are
important but where the mall is and
what's around it is also just as
important looking at Palladium there's a
tram stop right next to it a metro
station and it's a corner away from
masarikova the commuter rail station
Palladium is very easy and convenient to
get to so what you might say us malls
have ample parking and they are easy to
get to as well by car if sure but that's
part of the problem core Centric US
cities are more spread out which means
the mall will be further away from you
now then you want to buy an item say you
want to find a birthday gift for your
aunt or something do you then get in
your car drive down to the mall get
through a traffic jam trudge across the
parking lot then look for a gift and
then do the same process on the way back
home or do you just go ah it and
order something from Amazon with
Palladium even if I live on the
outskirts I can just go by Metro and be
there dirty door in about half an hour
once again this is from the edge of the
city American malls are usually not
built near any meaningful public transit
in fact they are usually not built near
any meaningful Place compare these these
four European malls two from Prague and
two from Budapest with these four
American malls from Phoenix Las Vegas
Oklahoma City and Orlando the reason why
Amazon and similar online Commerce
platforms cannot compete with the first
group but can threaten the second group
is because moles in the first group are
integrated into the city the surrounding
environment isn't just a parking lot
there are things to do and see and you
can end up in those walls even
completely organically as in unplanned
as part of you walking around downtown
with the second group you have to make a
conscious effort to go there nobody will
trudge through a kilometer of parking
lots on foot the GPS won't take you
there spontaneously you have to make the
decision at home to go there and then
make the effort then companies like
Amazon come along and say hey buddy we
can save you all that effort and so them
all for dying moles hell all comers has
to be an organic part of towns and
cities people should be able to get to
them by means other than a car and
conveniently such integrated commercial
spaces are far more resilient if your
commercial spaces aren't resilient if
you just plop a big box outside the town
don't be surprised when it goes bust in
a few years and that it's bulldozed for
the next thing to be put up for it to go
past the same way and then get bulldozed
and then the next thing and the next and
the next so on and so forth and this is
why many American malls are either dead
or dying in the end it all comes down to
policy economic and urban planning if
you're an American and want to do
something about this strong towns is
just your organization for you fighting
for the exact things I've mentioned in
this video aiming to create living
resilient human-centric places instead
of the mass-produced car-centric retail
deserts so do check them out and I thank
everyone for watching and as a reminder
you can use my link in the description
to get up to 35 of extra products and
I'll be seeing you next time at the mall
foreign